Let me give you some advice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The process of doing
your second draft
is a process of making
it look like you knew
what you were doing all along.
Writing a novel is like
driving through the fog
with one headlight out.
You can't see very
far ahead of yourself.
But every now and again,
the mists will clear.
In my class, I'm going to
tell you what stories are.
I'm going to give you some tips.
I'm going to give you some
exercises, and most of all,
I'm going to give you a little
push forward that you might not
have had.
Here we go.
I'll go through the whole thing,
because it's fairly short,
and it does a whole bunch
of stuff with character.
And then I'll tell
you what I did.
I have writer's block.
I cannot write.
Sounds like something that
you can do nothing about.
That, of course, isn't true.
Why don't I take you through
the process of plotting a comic?
Sandman 19.
I can give you how I
do it and how I did it.
You do it like this,
your thumbnails
will only be seen by you.
You definitely don't
have to show them
to an artist who
can actually draw.
Worldbuilding is honestly the
joy of getting to play God.
Every little detail that
you can smuggle with you
into your fiction
makes your world
more real for your reader.
And you know, of course, that they're
just smudges in the background.
But that's OK, because
it was informed
by you and an imagination.
Human beings are
storytelling creatures.
Stories are vital.
We convey truth with stories.
That is the magic of fiction.
You need that conviction
that you are brilliant.
This is the greatest idea
that anybody's ever had.
And that by writing it, you
will set the world on fire.
I'm Neil Gaiman, and
this is my MasterClass.